[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute geht so süß daher
wir machen nämlich etwas richtig süßes
aus der türkischen küche und zwar machen
wie heißt noch mal passen masse mit
katar fall so dürft euch darunter
folgendes vorstellen wir haben eine
milch pudding den wir auf engelshaar
ausbreiten engelshaar das sind diese
teig heben zeige ich euch gleich auch
und ich beginne auch direkt ihr findet
ja wie immer die ganz genaue
mengenangaben unten der video
beschreibung und haben wir beide starten
jetzt direkt also ich hab jetzt hier
mein engelshaar was ich jetzt so grob
durchschneide weil es klebt dann schon
ziemlich zusammen und die fäden sind
auch relativ lang
daher kann man grob durchschneiden und
dann geht es auch schon in die pfanne
[Musik]
so das englisch haben muss auch noch so
ein bisschen auseinander gerupft werden
wir das schon ziemlich zusammengepresst
ist also macht es einfach in der pfanne
direkt und dann geben wir butter mit
dazu und das ganze soll jetzt richtig
schön ja so rötlich braun werden damit
auch was fürs auge ist wenn jetzt auch
richtig schön knusprig ist und gut
schmeckt so dass nimmt jetzt auch ein
paar minuten zeit in anspruch also ihr
müsst schon so mit fünf minuten rechnen
bis es hier richtig schöne bräune erhält
und jetzt geben wir puderzucker dazu
weil es schon gern ein bisschen süßen
möchte aber kein kristallzucker oder
zucker kann sich jetzt besser auflösen
und sobald es sich aufgelöst hat gebe
ich alles auf mein backblech
[Musik]
es ist ganz wichtig dass ihr die karte
eismasse jetzt total gerade und
gleichmäßig verteilt das blech das
brauchen wir jetzt erstmal nicht wir
machen jetzt den pudding und dafür habe
ich hier milch in einem topf und da gebe
ich jetzt folgende zutaten hinzu
natürlich ca für die süße dann habe ich
hier mail und vanillepudding pulver und
wenn ihr mich kennen dann wisst ihr dass
ich zum vanillepudding pulver immer noch
vanille extrakt mit dazu gebe weil mir
das sonst viel zu wenig meinen geschmack
ist und es ist ja auch künstliche
vanille da drin und hier haben wir dann
echte vanille damit aromatisiert dass
noch mehr und dann ruhig das um so dass
es klein bisschen frei ist und
anschließend geht's unter höheren ein
mal aufgekocht
das gehört ja
[Musik]
es ist der pudding schön dick habe den
herd ausgeschaltet und gebe jetzt butter
dazu dass lasst ihr in der hitze einfach
schmelzen und potsdam unter
[Musik]
so und jetzt geben wir den pudding noch
im heißen zustand das ist ja wichtig
damit er eben nicht festhielt und ihnen
verstreichen könnt gehen wir nicht auf
die kdf schicht und das am besten
gleichmäßig damit ihr so wenig wie
möglich verstreichen müsste schütze habe
ich es einfach weg getan ich echt war
mit den ganzen nicht anfahren
das ist so sad ist ein lieblingswort ist
wirklich das mal an ich liebe pudding
so beim verstreichen mit der winkel
palette darauf achten dass er wirklich
vorsichtig verstreicht und ganze langsam
mit ganz viel gefühl
so und jetzt muss es eigentlich nur noch
auskühlen er wies auf rollen können das
ist ganz wichtig entweder bei
raumtemperaturen dauert erheblich länger
oder im kühlschrank ich bin nicht so
schlau achtung werbung
ich werde jetzt die bügel hier einfach
einfahren von meinem backblech dann
passt das nämlich wunderbar dann hier in
den kühlschrank und dann dauert auch
nicht so lange dann kann ich gleich
schon mal weiter rolle aufbau ist ja
also bis gleich so das war's bei mir für
circa 45 minuten im kühlschrank und
jetzt richtig schön auskühlen fest
werden und jetzt nehmt euch ein messer
oder so ein teil grad und schneidet euch
streifen und die streifen werde ich dann
nochmal halbieren damit ich eben nicht
so große röhrchen habe sie sollen ja
auch so richtig mundgerechte portionen
gerecht sein so ich stehe jetzt einfach
mal was los
[Musik]
solche rollen zweiter vor mich hin
verabschiedet euch aber schon mal ihr
könnt natürlich bei der deko variieren
ich jetzt ganz klassisch pistazien es
für mich immer so typisch türkisch und
generell typisch orientalische was ich
auch gesehen habe was viele machen sind
müsste noch mit rein tun zb walnüsse
genug kokosnuss du noch mit rein profis
aufrollen ich mag es lieber pur oder ihr
könnt auch saucen obendrüber geben
schokosoße zb ganz wie ihr möchtet und
ich wünsche euch jetzt einfach mal ganz
viel freude beim nachmachen und ich
freue mich jetzt schon über eure fotos
auf instagram da markierte mich dann
fleißig dann kann ich jetzt ihren posten
und ansonsten noch einen wunderschönen
tag und bis zum nächsten mal lustige
sketche
[Musik]